PLEASE IN GERMAN THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE WITH US TODAY THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON VETERANS
AFFAIRS -- WILL BEGIN SHORTLY
BUT I JUST WANT TO SHARE
SOMETHING WITH YOU BEFORE WE GET
OFFICIAL BUSINESS I AM SO PROUD.
THAT I BELIEVE THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME WE'VE EVER HAD THE FLAGS
REPRESENTING ALL BRANCHES OF
SERVICE.
OF CENTERS WE'VE NEVER DONE THAT
SO I REQUEST IT.
AND EVEN TO THE POINT WHERE I
SAID I WOULD BUY THEM I JUST
NEED MY FLAGS UP HERE.
BECAUSE WE'RE HERE TO HONOR MEN
AND WOMEN IN UNIFORM AND THOSE
WITH SERVICE GREAT COUNTRY.
SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO ASK IN
THE AUDIENCE FOR ALL OUR
VETERANS TO PLEASE STAND TO BE
RECOGNIZED.
ARMY NAVY AIR FORCE MARINE CORPS
COAST GUARD.
AND PLEASE.
CENTER TOM ARNOLD.
AND I I THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE --
IF I HAD IT MY WAY WOULD HAVE
THE MARCHING BAND OUTSIDE.
WELL LET ME LET ME MISTER CHAIR
IF I COULD MAY YEAH SUGGESTION
THAT BEFORE ANY BILLS PRESENTED
THAT THE AUTHOR HALF. TO ONE
SERVICE AND SING THEIR SERVICE
SONG.
RELEASED A FEW BARS THEIR
SERVICE SONG BEFORE PRESENTATION
THAT WOULD BE GOOD I WILL CHANGE
BUT NOT WITH MY VOICE I'M
TELLING YOU WELL YOU'D BE IN
TROUBLE.
BUT ANYWAY ONCE AGAIN LET'S JUMP
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
WE ARE I THINK THE BEST.
COMMITTEE THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE
ARE BLESSED TO BE ABLE TO HONOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO SERVE THIS
GREAT COUNTRY.
AND THAT WE'RE ALL WORKING HARD
TO MAKE SURE WEEK KNOWLEDGE YOUR
SERVICE.
AND ALSO BRING TO LIGHT SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO
YOU THE ISSUES THAT THAT --
PERTAIN TO YOUR BRANCH OF
SERVICE FOR JUST ANYONE OF YOU.
WHO HAS?
SUFFERED AND AND IN A IN
MILITARY SERVICE.
AND WE'RE HERE TO TO TO
ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR SERVICE AND
THANK YOU AGAIN.
SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND BEGIN.
WITH THE WITH THE ROLL CALL AND
AND SECRETARY.
YES SIR ARCHULETA HERE.
GROWTH RICARDO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
WELL.
WE HAVE A QUORUM LADY JUMMA SO
THEN WE CAN GO TO WORK -- SO WE
HAVE FOUR BILLS TO LOOK AT SO
LET'S GO AHEAD AND START WITH
THE VERY FIRST.
ONE WHICH IS AB TWO FORTY IS A
REPRESENTATIVE HERE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
MEMBER IRWIN WOULD YOU PLEASE
PRESENT AB.
TWO FORTY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE.
I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THE
FLAG UP THE BLOOD I WILL
ABSOLUTELY NOT BE SINGING.
SO GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS LAST YEAR I
REQUESTED AN AUDIT OF LEASES AND
OTHER USES OF THE REAL PROPERTY
AT THE CALIFORNIA VETERANS HOMES.
THAT AUDIT WAS RELEASED EARLY
THIS YEAR AND FOUND THAT IN
VIOLATION OF THE LAW LEASES HAVE
BEEN GRANTED TERMS THAT WERE TOO
LONG.
AND DID NOT PROVIDE A BENEFIT TO
THE HOMES.
AND DID NOT APPROPRIATELY
COMPENSATE STATE.
ADDITIONALLY A NUMBER OF OTHER
INAPPROPRIATE USES OF THE HOME
PROPERTY CAME TO LIGHT.
THIS BILL WOULD MAKE LAW OUT OF
THE AUDITOR'S CHIEF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IMPROVING
LEASE TERMS AND ENSURING THAT
THE USES OF THE PROPERTY PROVIDE
A BENEFIT TO THE RESIDENTS OF
THE HOMES AND ARE CONSISTENT
WITH THEIR PURPOSES.
THE BILL WOULD STRENGTHEN AND
THEREBY EXISTING LAW LIMITING
THE LEASES TO FIVE YEARS WHILE
GRANTING SOME DESIRED
FLEXIBILITY FOR PUBLIC AGENCIES.
AND FOR NONPROFIT CENTER RIGHT
PROVIDING SERVICES EXCLUSIVELY
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
RECOGNIZING THE WAY THE OFF THE
HOME IN PARTICULAR IS A
SIGNIFICANT COMMUNITY MEMBERS
HIS USE THAT.
PAUL TO ORGANICALLY OVER --
YEARS MANY YEARS THIS BILL ALSO
PROVIDES A FRAMEWORK FOR LEGALLY
GRANTING LONGER TERM LEASES.
PROVIDED THERE IS LEGISLATIVE
APPROVAL.
AND ADDITIONAL PROVISION WILL
PROVIDE SOME INCENTIVE FOR
LEASES WITH THE LONGEST TERMS
WHICH CURRENTLY HAVE THE STATE
LOCKED UP FOR DECADES TO OPEN UP
TO RENEGOTIATE AND RENEGOTIATE
THEIR CONTRACTS PROVIDE.
ARMS TO THE HOMES.
WITHOUT BEING FORCED TO GIVE UP.
OF THE LENGTH OF THEIR CONTRACTS.
WHICH ANALYSIS HAS ALREADY FOUND
THE STATE MAY NOT UNILATERALLY
BREAK.
THIS BILL STRENGTHENS EXISTING
STANDARDS BY REQUIRING THAT.
GIVEN USE PROVIDES A SUBSTANTIAL
AND DIRECT BENEFIT TO THE HOMES
AND ITS MEMBERS.
AND DOES NOT SUPPORT THE HOMES
FUNCTION AS LONG TERM CARE
FACILITY.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING HARD TO
STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN
GRANT AND FLEXIBILITY UNDER THE
LAW THAT KNOWLEDGE IS LONG
STANDING AGREEMENTS.
AND CREATING A RIGOROUS
STANDARDS THAT ENSURES THAT THE
HOMES ARE OPERATED PRINCIPALLY.
FOR THE BENEFIT OF CALIFORNIA
VETERANS AND THIS BILL DOES.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE.
HE'S JUST YOUR SUPPORT OKAY BUT
SO WITHTHAT I'D LIKE TO KIND OF
BACKTRACK JUST A LITTLE BIT I
KNOW WE'VE HAD A COUPLE SENATOR.
THE MEN WITH YOU -- YOU DON'T
NEED TO KNOW OKAY VERY GOOD.
OKAY.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT.
OF THE BILL [inaudible]
WE COMPORT.
REPRESENTING AMERICAN GI FORUM.
ALL IN THE VIETNAM VETERANS OF
AMERICA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEW MEMBERS I ACT AND PRESIDENT
REAGAN'S FAVORITE BIRTH THE ARMY.
IF YOU'RE READY.
ANYWAY -- COMMANDER LORRAINE
JUST AND THE AMERICAN VETERANS
AND THAT SYSTEM THE PART OF THIS.
GOOD VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
OKAY.
IN A I HAVE [inaudible]
THE MOTION.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ASK OUR
STANDARD ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
REMEMBER.
SELECT QUOTE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR VERY GOOD.
OKAY GO HEAD TO ROLL.
AB TWO FORTY TWO PATHS FIRST
REFER TO SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION ARCHULETA.
HI EXCELLENT I GREW.
AYE AUTO.
I NIELSEN HI I'M WRONG BUT I AM
BURKE.
NUMBER I WILL.
WILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF LETTERS.
YOU CERTAINLY MAN ACTUALLY MAKE
THE WE HAVE A MOTION.
SENT.
THE BOOK PLEASE OKAY.
AT EIGHTY THREE SIXTY ONE TO
PASS BUT RATIONS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION CONSENT CALENDAR
ARCHULETA I LETTER I WROTE.
I THOUGHT OF I NIELSEN.
IRA.
I AMBER NUMBER I WILL I WILL
COME.
AND THE MEMBER RAMOS PLEASE AT
IF YOU'RE READY.
MEMBER RAMOS I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE.
GOING TO PRUDENT A. B..
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX VETERANS
SECURITY AND CLEARANCE.
YES SAYS LORE THAT'S CORRECT
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU AND AND
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS FOR THE
FIRST OF THE EXCEPT IN THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON AB.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SIX ASSISTS VETERANS
WITH WORK EXPERIENCE AND
CYBERSECURITY. TO EASILY
TRANSITION FROM SERVICE TO
EMPLOYMENT.
IN WHICH BACKGROUND CHECKS ARE
REQUIRED.
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES OFFER A VARIETY OF
WORK FORCE AND EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS TO ASSIST MILITARY
PERSONNEL. TO OBTAIN DEGREES AND
REACH PATHWAYS TO PROFESSIONAL
CIVILIAN CAREERS.
THERE IS CURRENTLY NO UNIFORM
HIRING SYSTEM IN PLACE FOR
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIESWITH
THE STATE.
IT ACCOUNTS FOR A VETERANS PAST
EXPERIENCE IN CYBER SECURITY OR
WHETHER HE OR SHE HOLDS OR HAS
HELD.
A NATIONAL SECURITY CLEARANCE.
FOR THESE REASONS AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SIX REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS TO COLLABORATE.
WITH SPECIFIC STATE AGENCIES TO
ESTABLISH A VETERANS PREFERENCE
TOWARDS.
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN
THE FIELD OF CYBER.
IT REQUIRES A SECURITY CLEARANCE.
IN ADDITION THIS BILL REQUIRES
STATE AGENCIES HIRING FOR
CYBERSECURITY POSITIONS TO
ESTABLISH A UNIFORM HIRING
POLICY. FOR VETERANS WITH
SECURITY CLEARANCE BACKGROUNDS.
WITH ME TODAY IS RICHARD VALDEZ.
A MARINE VETERAN AND PURPLE
HEART RECIPIENT REPRESENTING
DISABLED AMERICAN VETERANS THE
SPONSORS OF A. B..
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX HERE TO
TESTIFY AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE MISSED [inaudible]
YES.
WITH REGARDS TO A THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SIX I'M HAPPY TO REPORT
THAT.
SINCE WE BEGAN WORKING ON THIS.
I'VE BEEN COLLABORATING WITH THE
PROFESSORS AT BOTH CAL STATE
UNIVERSITIES UNIVERSITY EXAMINER
DINO.
AND ALSO CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
FRESNO.
THE PROFESSOR FRESNO.
MISTER ROCK KEITH CLEMENT IS A
MEMBER OF THE GOVERNOR'S
CYBERSECURITY CAST PORTION
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR.
ON NOT EDUCATION IT AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
WHEN THEY ARE BROUGHT THE FIRST
REPORT THERE WAS NO MENTION OF
THAT CAN SENATE?
SEC REPORT WHICH WERE REVIEWING
NOW AND PUTTING TOGETHER
RECOMMENDATIONS NOW HAS A
SECTION AND IT WITH RESPECT TO
TRANSITIONING.
A MILITARY DISABLED VETERANS AND
VETERANS.
I SEE THAT IS A PLUS UP AND PART
OF THAT IS BECAUSE OF WHAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING WITH REGARDS A. B..
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX DRAWING TO
THEIR ATTENTION THAT.
THE VETERANS ARE A RELIABLE AND
READY.
RESOURCE POOR NOT ONLY ACADEMIA.
GOVERNMENT AND INDUSTRY.
AS WELL AS OUR CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY SANDRA DINO --
PROFESSOR OF TWENTY COLSON
THERE'S NOW A GREATER VISIBILITY
ON THEIR PROGRAM WHICH IS THE
CSU CYBERSECURITY PROGRAM.
THROUGH A ROUTE CSU SYSTEM.
THERE'S NOW MORE ATTENTION
FOCUSED ON TRANSITIONING
VETERANS AND DISABLED VETERANS.
SO WHAT.
WE'RE MAKING STRIDES AND
HOPEFULLY -- THE US SENATE
COMMITTEE HERE I SEE IS THAT AND
COURTING THANK YOU SIR.
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SET THREE BUT
THREE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING AMERICAN LEGION AND
AND AM THAT.
ON SPORT THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
RIGHT UNDERSTOOD -- I THINK THE
AS AMENDED THE PRIMARY DRIVER IN
TERMS OF THE DEPARTMENT IS.
SHIFTS TO CHART.
AND SO I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE IF THAT IF I AM INCORRECT.
I JUST HAD A QUESTION -- IF I
MAY.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT THE ON JOHN
SPANGLISH TALK ABOUT THEIR IN
FACT WE HAD A CONVERSATION.
I SEE HAPPENING HERE IS JUST AN
EXTENSION OF WHAT CURRETLY KERN
COUNTY CAMP PENDLETON.
THROUGH A THE I. H. R. AND THAT
WOULD CAL THAT.
IN THE WAY I SEE THINGS
MATERIALIZE IN OVER OVER TIME AS
THIS BILL GOES FORWARD.
IS THAT YOU'LL BE A UNION OF OF
ACTIVITIES THAT WILL MAKE THE A
PIPELINE OF PATHWAY.
MUCH MORE -- GIVEN MORE CLARITY
FOR THOSE VETERANS ARE COMING
OUT OF THE SERVICE.
IN NOT ACADEMIA GOVERNMENT AND
AND INDUSTRY.
THANK YOU AM I AS SERVING AS A
VETERAN I KNOW THAT A LOT IN
MOLASSES TRANSLATE INTO THAT.
CIVILIAN WORLD RIGHT SO I THINK
YOU KNOW INSTEAD OF ITEMIZING
ANY OF THESE THINGS I'D LIKE TO
SEE JUST OPENING IT.
TRANSFERRED MILITARY SERVICE.
IN OS AND QUALITY OF JOHN
PERFORMANCE TRANSITION INTO THE
CIVILIAN WORLD.
WHETHER IT BE TRUCK DRIVERS WITH
EACH SECURITY.
IS WHETHER IT BE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS CHECK OUT YOU KNOW
JUDGES AT JACK OPPOSITE IS A
MATTER I'D LIKE.
THAT WOULD BE DISCREET IT'S
TRêN.
MILITARY EXPERIENCE RIGHT INTO
THIS.
THE BILL IT'S AN HONOR
[inaudible]
TO THANK [inaudible]
COMMENT [inaudible]
THE BILL.
AND I THINK YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
RIVAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE MOTION THE POOR AND THE
BILL.
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX AND DO
PASS AS AMENDED FIRST REFER TO
LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT.
ARCHULETA BY OUR LETTER I WROTE.
AYE AUTO.
I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I ROTH.
ROTH AYE NUMBER NUMBER I WILL
[inaudible]
LITTLE LITTLE [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BECAUSE OF THE
MOMENT [inaudible]
AND WE'LL PICK UP IN THE LAST
VOTE AND THAT'LL DO IT ORTEGA'S
TEACHER THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SO IRWIN.
YEAH.
WE HAVE A BE SEVEN SIX ONE
COMING UP.
GOVERNOR JERRY AND PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS.
CHANGE THE STATE ARMORIES IN THE
HOMELESS SHELTER REDDIT.
THANK YOU THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF MILITARY
TO USE ARM RECESS HOMELESS
SHELTERS.
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR WHEN THERE
ARE HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS SUCH AS
EXTREME HEAT AND THE SUMMER --
AS YOUR WORK ONE IS IN THE
MIDDLE OF A CRISIS WITH
HOMELESSNESS.
AS OF JANUARY TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA HAS AN
ESTIMATED HUNDRED AND
290-009-0070 TWO EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ON ANY GIVEN DAY
[inaudible]
THIS REPORT.
AS REPORTED BY CONTINUUM'S OF
CARE TO THE US DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT.
INTO THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
GREATER LO ANGELES HOMELESS
COUNT APPROXIMATELY 75% OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTIES. FIFTY THREE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WERE
ON SHELTER.
THIS PRESENTS IMMEDIATE THREATS
TO THE WELL BEING AND SAFETY OF
THOSE PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN LA COUNTY THE
NUMBER OF ANNUAL DEATHS OF
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
HAS RISEN TO EIGHT HUNDRED
NINETY NINE PEOPLE JUST IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ALONE.
THAT SAME YEAR OF THE MONTH WITH
THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF THAT'S WAS
IN THE MONTH OF JULY WHEN NINETY
THREE INDIVIDUALS THAT'S THE WAY.
STATE OWNED ARMORIES HAVE LONG
PROVIDED A RESOURCE THE
COMMUNITY SEEKING SITES. FOR
EMERGENCY SHELTER THIS BILL
ALLOWS ANY ARMORY DEEMED VACANT
BY DEPARTMENT OF MILITARY TO BE
MADE AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR. FOR SHELTERING HOMELESS
PERSONS FROM HAZARDOUS WEATHER
CONDITIONS.
THE SITES COULD BE USED TO SAVE
LIVES DURING HAZARDOUS WEATHER
EVENTS IN THE SUMMER WHEN
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS ARE EXPOSED.
TO DANGEROUS CONDITIONS WITH ME
I HAVE JEFFREY PROCTOR FROM THE
LOS ANGELES HOMELESS SERVICES
AUTHORITY.
AS WELL AS CHRIS MARTIN WITH
HOUSING CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU CENTER WITNESSES
[inaudible]
CARE.
ONE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
THINK FOR THE TIME TO COME
BEFORE YOU AND DISCUSS THE
CRITICAL CRITICAL ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS BASE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
MY NAME IS JEFFREY PROCTOR AND
I'M THE MANAGER OF SYSTEM
COMPONENTS FOR THE LOS ANGELES
HOMELESS SERVICES AUTHORITY.
ALSO COORDINATES THE DELIVERY OF
ANGELES CONTINUUM OF CARE.
WHERE ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND
PERSONS?
EXPERIENCE ALMOST AS ON THE
GIVEN NIGHT.
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN THERE WERE
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA.
OVER TWO THIRDS OR 69% OF
CALIFORNIA'S HOME IT ALMOST
POPULATION ARE ON SHELTERED.
SLEEPING ON THE STREETS AND
PARKS INTENSE AND IN THEIR CARS.
ABOUT NINETY THOUSAND PEOPLE
THAT ARE EXPOSED TO THE ELEMENTS
EVERY NIGHT AND EVERY DAY.
ALONG WITH THAT EXPOSURE COME
SERIOUS HEALTH RISKS.
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY ALONE
ABOUT NINE OR TO PEOPLE THAT
WERE HOMELESS DIED IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE VAST
MAJORITY OF WHOM DIED FROM
UNNATURAL DEATHS ACCORDING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY CORONER'S
OFFICE. FOR MORE PEOPLE DIE FROM
HYPOTHERMIA AND LOS ANGELES AND
COLDER REGIONS LIKE NEW YORK
ABOUT.
THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND STATEWIDE UNPRECEDENTED
EFFORTS ARE UNDER WAYTO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS.
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY VOTERS
APPROVED MEASURE H. A SALES TAX.
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE DOLLARS PER
YEAR TO COMBAT HOMELESSNESS.
THE STATE ALSO PROVED FIVE THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN ITS TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUDGET TO
REDUCE SOME.
THESE STRATEGIES RECOGNIZE UP
THE ONLY SUSTAINABLE WAY TO END
HOMELESSNESS IS PERMANENT
HOUSING.
SUPPORT OF HOUSING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING RENTAL SUBSIDIES AND
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING OR SOME OF
THE SOLUTIONS THAT WE ARE
INVESTING AND AND ALMOST.
SKILLING THESE INTERVENTIONS
TAKES TIME HOWEVER AND BARRIERS
TO PERMIT A NEW INTERIM HOUSING
PROCESS AND WOMEN ARE CAPACITY
TO BRING NEW SHOPPERS ONLINE
QUICKLY.
IN THE MEANTIME THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF OUR NEIGHBORS LIVING
ON THE STREETS AS AN URGENT
CRISIS.
WE NEED INTERMOUNTAIN
INTERVENTIONS SUCH AS CRISIS AND
BRITTAS SEEM TO BRING PEOPLE
INDOORS.
STATE OWNED ARMORIES HAVE BEEN A
CRITICAL TOOL IN OUR EFFORTS TO
SHELTER PEOPLE DURING THE WINTER
MONTHS.
OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT
HAS BEEN VITAL IN ENSURING THE
ALMOST AS THE LOS ANGELES HAS
BEDS TO BRING PEOPLE INDOORS AND
OUT OF THE RAIN.
BY MAKING USE OF UNDER UTILIZED
OUT.
THROUGHOUT THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS LHASA HAS WORKED WITH
MILITARY DEPARTMENT A SHELTER
PEOPLE IN THE SUMMER INGLEWOOD
CA MONA IN WEST LA ARMORIES AND
ONCE ANGELES COUNTY.
BUT THERE CONSIDERABLE
CONSIDERABLE HEALTH RISKS IN THE
SUMMER MONTHS AS WELL.
WHEN THE COUNTY CORNER THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF DEATHS OF
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN OCCURRED IN
JULY?
WHEN NINETY THREE ANGELENOS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS DIED
ON THE STREETS?
MOST ARMORIES HOWEVER ARE ONLY
AVAILABLE FROM OCTOBER FIFTEENTH
TO APRIL FIFTEENTH FOR THE
STATUTE.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP MAKE.
THEY CAN ARMORS AVAILABLE DURING
HAZARDOUS WEATHER AS WE APPROACH
THE HARDEST PART OF THE SUMMER
MONTHS WHERE THERE IN SEVERAL.
HEALTH RISKS TO OUR OWN CHILDREN
ALMOST PERSONS THE ABILITY.
TO PROVIDE AND CREATE NEW
SHOPPING OPPORTUNITIES AS THE
RECENTLY PERSONAL.
MORE BY USING VACANT ARMORIES
THIS BILL WOULD INCREASE ACCESS
TO SHELTER WITHOUT IMPINGING ON
THE NATIONAL GUARDS DUTIES.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION [inaudible]
YEAH -- I THINK -- CHRIS MARTIN
WITH A HOUSING CALIFORNIA
SENATOR WILL BECAUSE IT
RECOGNIZE CHRIS BARNES ALSO LEAD
SINGER COLDPLAY THAT'S MY THAT'S
MY DAY JOB THAT'S MY BUT I WHO
ARE GET HOUSING CALIFORNIA WE'RE
IN AND BECAUSE THE NONPROFIT.
OUR FOCUS ON ENDING HOMELESSNESS
IN INCREASING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR PEOPLE WHOSE WAGES ARE NOT
KEEPING UP HIGH HOUSING COSTS.
WHICH IS THE NUMBER ONE DRIVER
OF HOMELESSNESS IN OUR STATE.
HOUSING CALIFORNIA IN OUR LHASA
RECOGNIZE THAT THE ONLY
SUSTAINABLE WAY TO AND
HOMELESSNESS IS TO PERMANENT
HOUSING.
STATEWIDE SEVERAL SOLUTIONS TO
GET PEOPLE ON A PERMANENT
HOUSING ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED.
IN -- TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THIS
LEGISLATURE ALLOCATED FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
YOU SEE A PROGRAM AND AS WE
SPEAK -- AND PASSED ON SUNDAY --
SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION.
FOR MORE AID -- TO SUPPORT
INTERVENTIONS LIKE BERMAN
HOUSING.
WHAT'S GOING OF THESE
INTERVENTIONS DOES TAKE TIME AND
MEANWHILE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF OUR NEIGHBORS LIVING ON THE
STREET.
IS THAT ENERGY CRISIS.
MORE MORE RESIDENTS OF OUR STATE
FROM FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN TO
SENIORS ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AN ALARMING NUMBER
OF PEOPLE ARE ON SHELTERED
EXPOSED TO THE ELEMENTS DAY AND
NIGHT.
ALONG WITH THAT EXPOSURE COME
SERIOUS HEALTH RISKS AND
INCREASED LIKELIHOOD OF DEATH.
STATE OWNED ARMORIES HAVE BEEN
CRITICAL TOOL IN OUR STATE'S
EFFORTS TO SHELTER PEOPLE DURING
THE WINTER MONTHS.
BUT THEY'RE ALSO CONSIDERABLE
HEALTH RISKS IN THE SUMMER
MONTHS AS THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER
OUTLINED.
AB SEVEN SIXTY ONE WOULD HELP BY
MAKING VACANT ARMORIES AVAILABLE
DURING HAZARDOUS WEATHER.
MOREOVER BY USING VACANT ARMORY
THIS BILL WOULD INCREASE ACCESS
TO SHELTER WITHOUT IMPINGING ON
THE NATIONAL GUARDS DUTIES.
HOUSING CALIFORNIA IS PROUD TO
SUPPORT AB SEVEN SIXTY ONE AND
COMMANDS THE AUTHOR FOR HIS WORK
ON THIS TOPIC.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER
THANK YOU AND MY FELLOW SENATORS
AND AUDIENCE THAT JUST LIKE.
POINT OUT AT THE SOLE DISCRETION --
TO USE THE ARMORY -- SHABIHA BY
THE ADJUTANT GENERAL BUT IT
SHALL ONLY BE IF THE ARMY IS
TAKEN.
NOT USED BY OUR MILITARY
PERSONNEL THE NATIONAL GUARD.
SO I EMPHASIZE THAT BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE ASKING CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT.
BUT IT'S ONLY WHEN IT DEEMED
BACON AND NOT IN USE SO WITH
THAT.
WE ASK FOR ANYONE WHO'S
SUPPORTING THE BILL TO COMPORT.
THE COLD WAR LIMóN ON THE HAVE
THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ALSO SPORTING.
ALORS BUILDER WITH CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL [inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD [inaudible]
NOT.
I HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE AND ANY.
COMMENT.
THIS MEDICARE VICE CHAIR.
AND I'M SUPPORTER OF THE BILL SO
DON'T TAKE IT QUESTIONS.
I AM [inaudible]
LIKE EXPOSE.
I'M IT'S EIGHT NINETY NINE LOTS
THEIR LIVES ON THE STREET WHAT'S
THAT.
SOME I'M SURE WHETHER ARSONISTS
JUST LOOKING STREET.
THERE WAS AN ARTICLE.
IT'S PRESENTED SHOT ANOTHER
[inaudible]
YEAH.
IF THAT HAPPENS IN AN ARMORED.
WE HAVE AN NGO IS THERE AN
OPERATOR THAT OPERATES IS -- IS
ARMORY THAT OPERATES THIS IN IT
IT ARMORY.
WHOSE LIABILITY OR EXPOSURE IF
THAT IS SOMEONE DIES ON THE
PREMISES OR IS MEDICALLY.
OR WHATEVER THE ISSUE IS WHO'S
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE THE STATE OR I
CAN SPEAK TO HOW WE OPERATE ARE.
OR HAVE SOARED WE OPERATIVE THE
ARMORS THAN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
THE POTENTIAL SOME OF THE
RESISTANCE ALREADY IS THE POINT
HOURS OF GETTING ANY WHAT'S
ANGELES.
AND WE'RE GOVERNMENT AGENCY WE
WILL ENTER INTO A LICENSING
AGREEMENT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT WHICH
OUTLINED.
OUR CONTRACTUAL REQUIREMENTS OR
HOW WE UTILIZE WHATEVER SPACE
THE ARE MADE AVAILABLE TO US AT
THE OUR RELOCATION.
THE CONTRACT THAT WE HAVE WITH
THE OPENING ORDER DEPARTMENT HAS.
A REQUIREMENT THAT WE PROVIDE ON
SITE SECURITY TWENTY FOUR HOURS
PER DAY.
THERE ARE ALSO ARMORY THESE THAT
WE CONTRIBUTE IN ADDITION TO
HAVING LICENSE THE ON SITE.
WHERE WERE PAYING FOR A NATIONAL
GUARD STAFF TO ALSO?
AS THE GROUNDS -- WE WONDER INTO
AN AGREEMENT WITH THE NONPROFIT
WRITER OR NOT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
INDICATION FILES OR ANYTHING I'M
JUST CURIOUS MY MAIN THING IS
THAT.
HE BUT IN THAT STATE.
MARKS BUT WHICH WHAT.
IS A GREAT YEAH SENATOR WAIT.
IF I CAN PUT YOUR MIND HE
CURRENTLY THIS PROGRAM ALREADY
EXISTS.
BETWEEN OCTOBER.
THE MONTH OF OCTOBER ALL THE WAY
TO THE APRIL.
IT BUT IT'S NOT IN USE.
BETWEEN APRIL OCTOBER THAT'S ALL
WE'RE OPENING IT UP.
IS THE EXTREME CONDITIONS
STARTED.
PREVIOUSLY WE WERE CONCERNED
PRIMARILY GIVEN.
THE BENEFITS OF I'M IN
CALIFORNIA WE WERE PRIMARILY
CONCERNED DURING THE OLD SEATS.
AND THE RAIN.
BUT NOW WE'RE ALSO AS CONCERNED.
WITH THE SUMMARY.
THAT'S WHY SO THIS PROGRAM IS
ALREADY BEEN IN PLACE AND HAS
BEEN UTILIZED.
ISN'T IT IN A PLACE LIKE.
IN MY TIME WITH LOS ANGELES
SERVICES THIRTY I'M NOT ANY WHAT.
THANK YOU ANY.
COMMENT.
THE QUESTIONS THAT I WOULD HAVE
NUMBER ONE I THANK YOU FOR WHAT
YOU'RE DOING.
WE HAVE.
AN ISSUE THAT THERE AND WE ARE
ALL SHE HAD THAT IN THE LA TIMES.
JEFF IS SCHOOL PAPERS TO CROSS
CITY CALIFORNIA.
OF ARE WE HAVING AN OUTREACH
PROGRAM TO IDENTIFY THOSE
VETERANS MIGHT COME THERE AND
WORK THEM INTO THE BE A SYSTEM.
TO COMMENT ON THAT.
WE HAVE -- POINTED OUT REACH
EFFORTS ACROSS THE COUNTY LOS
ANGELES -- WHICH ALSO INCLUDES
COORDINATION WITH THE THE
VETERANS AFFAIRS -- AND THERE'S
A SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS AND AN
OPERATIVE SPIRIT BETWEEN.
THE HOME SERVICE PROVIDERS HE
COUNTY AND SEE WHAT'S ANGELES AS
WELL AS THE VA AND SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS TO ENSURE THAT.
ALMOST BUTTONS ARE AWARE OF
SERVICES AND RESOURCES AVAILABLE
TO THEM.
WITH -- TARGETED RESOURCES
SPECIFICALLY -- THE ORGAN AND
FUNDED STREAMLINED FOR VETERANS
ACCESS -- WITH -- ONE OF THE
GREAT SUCCESSES IF WE HAVE ANY
TO POINT TO IN THIS YEAR'S
ALMOST COUNT.
IS THAT BETTER HOMELESSNESS MADE
BY.
THE PRIMARY PURPOSE IS I WOULD
HOPE IS BIRTH TRANSITION
[inaudible]
TEMPORARY.
HOUSING AND THEN SOME TRANSITION
INTO.
OTHER SERVICES WHETHER THEY BE
MEDICAL BASIC BUT WHATEVER IT
MIGHT BE.
AND I'M SURE THERE'S MEDICAL AID
THERE AS WELL.
YEAH THE ARMORY PROGRAMS THAT
WE'VE OPERATE IN THE PAST ARE
REALLY.
THE SERVER NUMBER DIFFERENT
FUNCTIONS BUT ONE IS TO BE THAT
UP FRONT DOOR INTO A GREATER
ARRAY OF SERVICES -- WHERE
PERSONS MIGHT NOT NORMALLY SEEK
ACCESS OF THE OTHER PARTS OF THE
YEAR -- WHEN IT IS OLD ENOUGH
PRODUCT OR WERE WENT OUT?
THEY'LL THEN GO AND SEE SERVICES
GET AS FAST IN TRIAGE.
AND I GET CONNECTED WHATEVER
THOSE RESOURCES SERVICES ARE
BASED ON THEIR THIRD.
ANSWER THAT PERCENT APPROVAL FOR
STOPPING GETTING WHAT.
WHICH CAN MEMBER THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT THANK YOU I HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
CENTER THANK YOU OF LOCAL
[inaudible]
ANOTHER QUESTION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK BRAD BOTH AND
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION.
AB SEVEN SIXTY ONE TO PASS.
THROUGH THE PERFORATIONS
ARCHULETA.
I ACTUALLY I WROTE.
AYE AUTO.
HOW DO I NIELSEN?
I ROTH ROTH AYE AMBER.
AMBER GUY WILL.
LOOK I'D.
SEVEN ZERO YES YOU VERY MUCH
OPEN THE ROLE.
PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX TO PASS
AS AMENDED FIRST REFER TO LABOR
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
WELL.
HI WILL KIND OF SEVEN ZERO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
GEN ONE I THINK THAT -- THIS
LOSER MADE I FEEL LIKE AS A
SPEED DATING HEARING